it merely points out that there's an
illusory experience it says
there's separation which then seeks
wholeness
which is where wholeness hides
and that just it just clarifies that
that's what's going on
wholeness hides in the illusory
separation
yeah wholeness is separation
the appearance of separation there isn't
anything else
that's why seeking it is hopeless
wholeness is the appearance of
separation there is only wholeness
yeah that's pretty interesting
it's mind-blowing
there's nothing to do with it yeah
maybe that's where the misunderstanding
that there's no that
one shouldn't do anything comes from
because the message itself
has no qual no no usable quality to it
it has no intention in it but it's
ineffable there's no way to point to the
unconditional
celebration because there is only that
because there is only that because
everywhere you point is the
unconditional celebration
the pointing as well the pointing is as
well yeah
wow so yeah so the unconditional
celebration is built synonymous with the
100 million people that died
in the 20th century and
it's also synonymous with pizza
[Laughter]
what this is crazy
oh my gosh got it is so crazy
cool there is only the infinite and yet
there is a zygote that apparently
becomes an adult
yeah which is this the infinite
appearing as the story of a zogo
becoming an adult which is this
okay okay cool
cool
[Laughter]
oh wow
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host atlas very
excited so pumped
to be featuring jim newman
on the show hi jim hey atlas
thanks so much for coming on the program
yeah thanks for inviting me
i'm really excited to talk about all
things
non-duality and jim has been
really influential on me and many others
and he's just got this style
of sharing the paradoxical message of
non-duality with these very
direct aphorisms like there is no path
this is home for no one
and he's hosting meetings worldwide and
monthly zoom meetings
and you can find all the content on his
youtube channel the links are in the bio
below to both his website
simply dash this dot com and his great
channel we are
going to be exploring the ineffable
basically
so how do we even do this jim so is it
is it then fair to say that
these meetings these
conversations are
pointing to what can't be pointed to
yeah yeah totally
[Laughter]
but we do it
because people come to attend
yet the meeting and to hear the
paradoxical message
yeah yeah it's an unusual it's it's
unexpected in a way because it's not
really presenting anything
it's responding to something that's
looking for something
and the response is there's nothing
really lost
so there's nothing there's nothing to
give there's nothing on
offer the message is really empty
it's it's no thing responding
to something saying i need something
more
and the response is that that experience
is
illusory as i've been
watching your content you've
said things like you seek
the end of the need to become
and so then that is what comes to the
meetings
well not really okay um what's what's
truly i mean in the end
there's you have to differentiate a
little bit and it can be a little
pedantic but the individual
that experience really just seeks more
it's an experience of knowing and what
it does is it seeks more knowing in the
hope
that when it knows enough it will find
what it feels is lost
what what's not obvious to it is that
seeking
or knowing knowing is the need to know
it's not the end of knowing knowing
engenders the need to know
but what's longed for beyond that
contracted
limited experience of being an
individual
is the end of seeking the end of the
need
to become yeah
yeah and
another way you've mentioned this is
that
there's this apparent center
that wants meaning it wants
purpose more and it's seeking to bridge
the gap
of separation yeah yeah
yeah and so just to be very clear
because it's so
often misunderstood there's a contracted
energy in the body which is an
appearance
and out of that arises the personal
experience of i
am which is completely illusory
it's not happening like it's not
happening
now it never happens but out of that
contracted energy
for that for that body it might be the
experience that it is happening
and the response is and there can be
nothing done about that
the response is it's not real it's
illusory everything else
the apparent world the apparent
contraction the apparent movement
is just seemingly so it's neither real
nor unreal the only thing that's
completely illusory or a dream is the
experience of being an individual
that everything is about me
so then it's a
it's a contracted
apparent center
that i am
an individual comes to the meeting
and then there's a process of the
pointing to the paradoxical message of
non-duality
of there is no path this
is home for no one and
at that point then as
is sort of said in the neo advaita
tradition
that there's a immediatism
of a sense of the
recognition of the illusion of the eye
or ego well nobody
nobody realizes the illusion of the eye
or the ego
it's it the one of the issues for the
individual is when it
when it's seeking it's expecting or the
need
says that what has to happen is there
has to be an answer
to my experience and that answer has to
be an addition to me
because i feel there's some sort of miss
something missing or something lacking
and so i i then look for a realization
i then look for something more because i
experience
something missing that never that that
never has an end that's an
eternal experience of seeking seeking
seeking seeking seeking is never
satisfied
but what the the meeting isn't about
hearing something
and something happening it merely
reflects
back to the experience that something
needs to happen
that nothing does and that that
experience that something needs to
happen
actually hides the reality
that what is is already completely free
and that includes the need experiential
need for something to happen
and that's the dilemma for the
experience of the individual
it is already what it's longing for well
what's long for it doesn't long for that
it doesn't long for its end it's
terrified at the end of itself
would it be fair to say that
some of the
ways of
adding attributes because
ultimately as i said the near guna
brahmin
is that without attributes the absolute
without attributes and then the saguna
brahman is when you add
attributes to the ultimate to the
absolute to the ineffable
and then that's sort of where you've
said things like
that this is already whole that there's
no
there's no lack it's unconditionally
free yeah
yeah so the in i don't know those two
terms that you talked about but what's
what's obvious
is they aren't actually two things yep
so the one doesn't become the other
the the appearance of
of um limitedness is the absolute
appearing limited the experience of
separation
is the absolute appearing as the
experience of separation
there never is separation that's the
dilemma for the individual it's trying
to overcome something that isn't
already happening
so the absolute appears as separation
no well yes it is separation it appears
as that
it's not separate from that it doesn't
become separation
so what what is
is already absolute yep correct
yeah and there's nothing else yes
all that is appearing is absolute
and that the
the appearance of separation
is then why there's the attendance of
the non-dual meetings yeah the
experience of separation yeah
the experience of being an individual a
person with a life
free will and choice meaning and purpose
yeah i mean it can be there are times
there are people that come to the
meetings just because it's
it's just a wonderful thing to hear
it's just a beautiful thing it's just
amazing really
it's it always remains fresh and new
it never becomes something old um and
known
so that and that fresh newness is
is is awesome it's just aliveness
so that can be you know
yep isn't there
something that's so beautiful
about the will
of this appearance that
feels like the
the appearance of the separate
individual that
is in a sense kind of like a
gps callback
mechanism i wouldn't say that i wouldn't
say that's beautiful at all
okay and there's nothing
that that there's nothing that has lost
wholeness and there's nothing that finds
wholeness so there's no journey
that that ex-separate individual or
experience is truly on
that journey is an illusion
that journey is the experience that this
appearance
has a real past and a real future
that happens as a cause and effect
continuum
that's an illusion that's actually death
real time is the fear of death
which is a big problem for me that
experience of separation
so no in that sense i don't see anything
amazing about it at all it's actually
it's actually you know just quietly
suffering
always looking for something always
trying to add something more to itself
coming from the coming to the appearance
with the experience that something is
wrong
and needs to be set right one of the
basic energies of that experience is
something needs to happen
which is a discontent it even it and
what it does is it will hear what we're
sharing here
and say something needs to happen for
this to understand or find what jim's
talking about
and that is the illusion jim isn't
coming from something that's known
it might be that the ones listening is
coming from something what's known
and thinks that jim has something they
don't and it's just the opposite
there isn't anything here there might be
the illusion of something there
that's fascinating that
there's a rather than
viewing it as beautiful
that there's also this view of it being
a quiet
suffering
i don't know how fascinating it is but
it it seems to happen
i mean that's that's the experience of
being an individual
something's missing something's wrong
something needs to happen
i mean intrinsically the entire
appearance of which that
and zen apart is awesome is beautiful
yeah but when you say is there something
beautiful in it that seems to me as if
it has some
sort of intention or some sort of
function sure
and it and it doesn't this doesn't have
any intention
that's the unconditional unrecognizable
freedom that it is that
there's no intention there isn't any
need for this to become
and it doesn't this doesn't become
do you also explore
the infinitude
that this is well you can't explore
the infinitude that this is because
there is only
the infinitude that this is okay
so then so then would it also be
fair to say that this is one
appearance of the infinitude no
because that suggests that there's
potential
that's unrealized
and and that's not the case there isn't
potential unrealized
because there isn't any where or
anything else
potential unrealized comes from an
experience that this
is really happening and it could be
something else that's not really the way
it is
this isn't really happening but it could
be anything
and in that the revelation is it is
anything it is already anarchy
or chaos it just appears as this
yes that's been a fun attribute
is metaphysical anarchy that's been an
interesting way to
express the ineffable
now when we do
play with infinity or eternity
that this is
the appearance of
metaphysical anarchy and that
is eternal or infinite
so eternal wouldn't be a word i would
use so why do you not use eternal
well a friend of mine just just informed
me that internal means
an age if you look it in the in the
dictionary
as a literary term it's defined as an
age
for me a little a little a little
cheeky i say it's just a very long time
eternal and infinity
so eternal is like a very long time
whereas for me
infinite points to that this i thought
eternal means without time
okay well if it does then that's that's
then
yeah that's this okay okay
and affinity for me is what does and
doesn't
there's no beginning and no end the
alpha and omega
yeah yeah yeah this okay cool
cool okay so then it does sound like
then eternity being no time
and infinity being no beginning no end
this yeah same thing yeah cool
cool okay but you don't
say that this is an expression
of that because you don't
want there to be the
the inference that there is something
more for it to achieve
well when you say it's the expression of
that it sounds like
and this isn't because this wants it
it's just because it's obvious
that there's no separation between
the what you're calling the ineffable
and the appearance
yes yes it's the same thing correct yes
which is not can't be understood
which is why it can't be pointed to
because pointing
is also it every word is it
it can't be contained because it is
everything
one word is everything
the experience that it that it that it
develops or becomes
is the experience that there's intention
or something's incomplete
and so something could happen really
happen
that would make a difference to that
which we're talking about
nothing does
you've called this empty
happening yeah okay cool cool
so would it be
fair to say that the
empty happening is similar
to in the
revelations in the last hundred or so
years
of quantum mechanics that there are
all of these infinite modulations
of the underlying energy
and that then this is an appearance
as form yeah but that's what happens and
that is what science does and that's
what the individual does is it says
there's all this possibility or
potential
that appears as certain things and
that's just the experience that there's
something other
than the appearance there isn't
the absolute is not hidden
the multitude of as you called it of
possibilities
isn't hidden it's only the experience
that what's happening is real
makes it seem like there's something
else this is the multitude of
possibilities
this is the absolute it doesn't
become because it is so there isn't any
outside
like god that's becoming or projecting
this this is all
yeah which is and isn't
so the aphorism from
john 10 30 that is i and my father are
one or
yeah or the or the sanskrit
tatvam asi you are that
you are that i wouldn't say i wouldn't
say you are that
you wouldn't but we do say this is the
ineffable but you wouldn't say that
you are that well we
are the word you and the word i
can be misleading so but what about we
are it or we are that well there if
there's no i there's no we
but you also said i and my father are
one is okay yeah because i understand
what you're saying but then you went you
gave me another one and i was thinking
oh i better
i better better get in there and sort of
clarify
that yes there's not two yep
there might be an appearance of two and
the appearance of
two as a reality comes out of the
experience that i
am or that you and
i am is simultaneously the experience
that you are
is it fair to say that in the most
ultimate that
there is no path
and that this is home for no one
and that
the appearance of the individual
is completely illusory and that
then simultaneously another layer
is that
this jim newman character
is a unique expression
yeah well there's a character yeah
that's unique expression yeah you could
say that
okay it's not another layer though it's
it's
it's all so
the reason why i even say it as another
layer
is just to be able to even slot it
into the conversation because sometimes
the individual is so
completely rejected that it never even
gets its ability to get slotted into the
conversation
yes but there's an appearance of a jim
newman unit
yeah character yeah and there's this
appearance of this atlas
unit slash character yeah and so
i feel as though that is
important okay and
the reason why is because
in the
understanding of the ineffable in the
attempt to
play in this territory that the
simultaneity of the
individual being a completely illusory
appearance while it also being a unique
expression oh no no no no unique
expression
is you know sort of the character of the
body we're talking about
an apparent past the brain conditioning
genetics that's that's the character the
voice how it happens this
the you know how how it moves how it
walks
that's the character the individual
never happens
so when when it's recognized or when the
the character the individual falls away
that doesn't actually fall away
the revelation is it never happened
so that's one of the misunderstandings
that often comes up is that it could
happen
that there's something that needs to
happen and so that's why there's
such an undermining of the experience of
the individual as a reality
and it's pointed out that it's
completely illusory because otherwise
it's heard as something wrong
and something that needs to change for
this to be complete and whole
yeah and that would be a
misunderstanding of what's being said
so the appearance of the jim newman
character
is anarchic yeah
just like all the words that are
happening yes the hands
it's all anarchy just appearing
and yet
do you find it beautiful
that there is this appearance of the jim
newman unit
character well especially the jim newman
character is beautiful yeah all the
other ones
especially
[Laughter]
[Music]
i mean you know the whole the whole
appearance
is is awesome is unspeakably
i mean creative yes the the
the individual in the experience of
knowing what's happening
loses the revelation of the aliveness
because the knowing is the experience of
what's happening is real
and that engenders the need for
something else the aliveness that seems
to be lost
and that aliveness is beauty
is purity and it it it is never it can't
be lost the experience of it being lost
is an illusion and i guess one reason
why when this comes out it totally
negates the experience of the individual
is because it is also that
aliveness and that beauty and the
seeking that it seems to do
is completely hopeless because it is
already
what's longed for and the seeking makes
it seem like it's lost
so there's nothing to say to the
individual there's just nothing to say
to it
it's actually not happening yeah yeah
so in the
ultimate there is nothing
to say to the individual
there's just this appearance happening
it's the immediacy there's no need for
anything to be said but things are said
and yes there's only immediacy
yeah which isn't real
it's not a now it's not a now that you
could be
and couldn't be it's not a now that you
could approach
it is it is it is that there is only
immediacy
even the experience that it's not
is immediacy is the
unspeakable creativity
of the quote
8 billion appearances
of units slash characters
yeah bodies bodies yeah
is that illusory multiplicity
that's not illusory that's apparent the
only illusion
the only illusion is the individual it's
just completely unreal
the bodies the apparent bodies atlas gym
camera cameras and computers and all
that are apparent
and that just merely points pointing to
that they're not
real they only they only become
experientially real
when the individual arises as real to
itself
i'm real everything else is real
okay so
all appearance is
unreal neither real nor
unreal yeah i see
and the
appearance being neither real nor
unreal
that when the
individual thinks
of itself as real
that then it says that the appearance is
real
it's it's more profound than that really
there when the individual arises it's
not a thought
it's an experience of knowing and when
the individual
that experience of knowing arises it
actually arises in everything
so everything becomes me
so everything is then real everything is
related to me and it's all
important or um in in my
life as me and that and what's
interesting is that includes what isn't
there and what isn't happening it's all
related to me it's
all about me and that's not a thought
the eye doesn't have thoughts what
happens is it it takes
in in that in that it takes ownership of
everything
it can't differentiate it picks up
everything because it's seeking it picks
up everything
it picks up thoughts and feelings as
well
and they feel closer to it and so it
feels more important to it
and it tries to do things with it as far
as sift through them to find the good
ones and the bad ones
and it has this big huge file cabinet
where it's making sense of everything
all the time
so it comes up a thought which doesn't
doesn't fit
to its story of itself it has a tool kit
where it drills a hole in here it cuts
off a corner because it's an
unacceptable thought doesn't fit to it
it's it's very it's very exhausting
being an individual
it's a lot of effort
and yet it is the way that
this is apparently expressed
what that the
it is exhausting i i'm 100 alignment
on how exhausting it is in the sense of
constantly seeking to in the in the
and having this in a sense this massive
sorting of of information
and yeah and that type of process and
then there's sort of the
this piercing of this veilless veil or
whatnot
the gateless gate that when that sort of
happens all of the seeking and the
filing cabinet stuff falls away
yes and that
yet it is the way that the appearance
happens is is that this
neither real nor unreal appearance
is a apparent jim newman character
and an atlas character that are
and eight billion bodies that
have this experience
of that that
apparently have this experience of
just of this happening yeah well
i mean i don't not to be too pedantic
but this isn't actually an experience
there isn't actually a consciousness in
the body
being aware of something else that's
just part
of the experience of being an individual
and then when when we go up and
sleep for a third of our lives and we
and we dream out the environment
and the observer in the environment and
then we
that dream ends where jim
simulated out a
uh himself being paul
by the eiffel tower and then he goes and
he simulates himself
out in a relationship with
karen in new york and so
that is analogous
to this is that how you view it
um well as the illusion of the
individual that something is really
happening but dreams happen
i dream
this isn't about changing the appearance
it's about the revelation that it's only
apparent it's not real
or unreal
and then is that similar to when you
become
paul in your in your dreamed reality and
you're hanging out with
the collapsing of becoming anything
so when that dream simulation happens
that's just what's happening that's just
what's happening and is this also that
yeah absolutely okay so you can't tell
the difference
you in a dream when you when you're
dreaming at night you have the
experiences it's
haphazardly begins somewhere but it
seems congruent
that's the experience anything goes on
in some sort of it's
whatever it does you don't know this
isn't that
you don't know that this hasn't just now
started
as some dream haphazardly and the brain
or the the
the atlas experience is making sense out
of it
you don't know
and that's when
we can potentially
leverage analogies like
the dream that
help with a
as you pointed earlier there's this
apparent
suffering of the seeking individual
and that the dream analogy can sort of
help
the cessation of the suffering
i don't i don't think anything helps the
association of suffering
it doesn't help anyone
it can it can't if it's understood there
can be some relaxation in the body
around it can be some some
loss of beliefs about what this
appearance was about
but there is no intention because
and you rightly pointed out it negates
the individual
completely and in as much it has no
message
to the individual it is not trying to
help anyone
because it doesn't recognize anyone
because quite simply there isn't anyone
so in the dream you're paul by the
eiffel tower
and that there's sally that comes up to
you
and that and that sally begins saying
that
that she encountered some sort of an
accident of some sort and that she
feels really bad that she
spilled really hot coffee
on somebody that she was dining with a
moment ago and she's telling you as
paul about it and that you
[Music]
you in that under
in this understanding that we're talking
about right now you
as paul would in the appearance of paul
would recognize that
both sally her suffering about spilling
the coffee
and then you listening to her
help helping her not suffer
that all of that in the grand scale is a
complete
apparent neither real nor unreal
dreamed it's just what's happening it's
just what's happening
yeah apparently
yeah that's all there is
is what seems to arise
and it is already whole and complete
so there isn't it doesn't have
it's it doesn't extend beyond it doesn't
have
any any limit to it
there isn't a beginning and an end to
that
which can't be said yes and that's why
the words infinite or eternal
in a sense they assist a lot
with the disintegration or the
dissolution
of the illusory i
am thought i am isn't a thought
experience it's an experience yeah if it
were a thought it'd be easy to deal with
and the reason this message is so often
rejected is because there's an
experience of i am
there's an experience of of awareness
there's an experience of
of consciousness and so rightly i mean
quite understandably this message is
rejected because
it goes against an actual experience and
for the individual
all it has all it knows
is experience
and then the individual never hears
what's being suggested
so this message is never heard by the
individual
but something else can let's say
sense it and and that
can then relax some of the
of the contracted contracted but that
without intention
nobody could do it just like this takes
absolutely no responsibility
for the message or anything that seems
to happen out of it because it doesn't
come from anyone or anywhere
exactly like this the appearance
it's already unconditionally free it
never becomes
unconditionally free yeah
is it fair to say that
the unconditionally
free wholeness
that is apparently happening
also has a
in a sense a dualistic concession
where there's a suffering and a
well-being
where there's people that don't have
their
basic needs being met where they don't
have access to clean water
yeah that seems to happen
and that it's exciting to talk about
the architectures and to execute those
that that enable more people to have
their basic needs met
yeah well i mean i'm sure there's
characters out there that would enjoy
doing that and some that wouldn't
why not sure building spaceships and
iphones and
yeah i think i think i think what you're
pointing to and i agree
that often this this sharing is
misunderstood
as sort of the negation of activity or
the negation
of a world where things can be done and
happen and really it's just negating
a personal volition that makes it happen
but of course all that stuff still
apparently happens
there's nothing right or wrong about any
of it the
judgment in the in the in what's being
shared here at all
it merely points out that there's an
illusory experience it says
says separation which then seeks
wholeness
which is where wholeness hides
and that just it just clarifies that
that's what's going on
wholeness hides in the illusory
separation
yeah wholeness is separation
the appearance of separation there isn't
anything else that's why seeking it
is hopeless
wholeness is the appearance of
separation there is only wholeness
yeah that's pretty interesting
it's mind-blowing
[Laughter]
there's nothing to do with it
yeah maybe that's where the
misunderstanding that there's no
that one shouldn't do anything comes
from because the message itself
has no qual no no usable quality to it
it has no intention in it yeah
i'm happy that
you mentioned that there's the
occasional
interpretation of non-duality
which will
make it feel like the creativity
of the expressions
is
not beautiful
yeah but it absolutely is beautiful
it's neither real nor unreal but it's
absolutely beautiful
the as we were listing meeting the basic
needs of people worldwide and
creating these incredible devices of
technology that enable us to communicate
and all this type of stuff
yeah but what you're doing now is you're
putting you're putting a value
on what would generally be called
helpful things
which negates other and what the
suggestion is
no matter what arises what you dislike
most
the worst thing you could think of and
the best thing you could think of
are all wholeness there is no
there is no difference in that sentence
and let's make the
dualistic concession and say that the
the person that makes
a loaf of bread
for their family is
feeding three or four people and that
the person that
teaches a million people
how to make loafs of bread is feeding
millions of people and so right now i'm
creating this
this atlas unit has the appearance of
making this value distinction
as you which is part of the dream
of hope of the individual the the
individual having
having that sense of lack or something
needing to happen
creates an entire system not as a choice
but as a reaction and and it creates a
belief system
in the belief system is its story about
itself about how it's going to find
wholeness and that belief system is
engenders or has within it the the um
values of good and bad and right and
wrong and it will come up with all sorts
of different things that it says
are good but that only relates to its
expectation that if it is good
it will find what it feels is missing
now this value system
where there's a conclusion it's just an
illusion yes
yes has no value yes
and then there's also the
value system where there's a suffering
there's
malevolence or violence or murder
rape and then there's the well-being
and prosperity and abundance and there's
sort of this dualistic concession in the
value system where
it's all still what is
which is neither real or unreal yes
and the eight billion
apparent bodies undergoing the
civilizational dialectical process
towards abundance and prosperity and
well-being and away from
violence and suffering is great
in in a dualistic reality yeah yeah in
the dualistic concession
this has been there's no concession here
dualistic of a dualistic reality that
has any value
from from that what we're talking about
actually it's obvious that the entire
appearance is already completely at
balance
yeah that it has no charge at all
that it actually has no need to become
i mean really there isn't another
eight billion people there isn't a world
out there
of suffering and hunger and all the
things we're talking about
just specifically there is simply what's
happening and
what you're bringing into the
conversation are these thoughts about
all of that
just like paul is
in your dream it's your thought
of paul
in the example to
try to illuminate this this conversation
in a sense it's almost as though
the infinite or the eternal
is a really great attribute along with
anarchy for
the non-dual and then
there's the
attribute of something like evolution
that's in a sense a good
attribute for the dualistic concession
there is the apparent evolutionary
process
where you went from being a zygote to
being a 30 trillion
celled unit character
yeah and that
appearance is useful
to know in
its appearance because
it gives insight
into the nature of the dream
yes no i see i don't agree with that
okay
so so for example when a child
recognizes the infant recognizes
that there is
no separation and that there is simply
this appearance happening
and yet also they recognize that
they went from being a zygote to being a
30 trillion celled adult
there's no value in the appearance
there's just simply no value in it
because it has no intention
value would send give the sense that
something was more valuable than
something else
that only arises when there's a sense of
need
there isn't any there isn't any need
there isn't any value
there's nothing wrong with the
recognition or the realization or the
knowing
that this body is the result of an
apparent
evolution that became something but at
the same time
this is the big bang
so there isn't any value in that process
because there isn't any real process
it's this appearing as that
process of a single cell becoming
but this is all of that
it seems as though with the
infinite or eternal
non-dual that
the ineffability of
that neither
real nor unreal appearance happening
this simply this that
that that in a sense
simultaneously
also
recognizing the
dualistic dichotomous
concession between the suffering and the
well-being
and the in the multiplicity the
concession of the eight billion apparent
bodies that are all
uniquely expressions of that infinite
eternal non-dual
it's the description of in a sense the
most outward of the inward
ness the inwardness is the
non-dual infinite ineffable eternal and
the
outwardness is this apparent
multiplicity of unique
units slash characters that are dreamed
that are neither real nor unreal but
it's still
cool that jim has this
unique iris
he has unique coloration around his
pupil
and that all 8 billion of us have unique
coloration in our iris around our pupil
and that that is in a sense an artistic
expression of that infinite of that
eternal of that non-dual
do you also kind of see it like a big
like artistic anarchic creative
expression well no i mean not
not as an experience not as an
experience but
as a creative anarchic
expression but that's this is a creative
anarchic but it's not
just to be clear it is
the ineffable yes yeah it is no
thing appearing as everything you just
said
i can't help but get the feeling you're
looking for some value in it
that somehow because it's artistic it
has more value
than something else and that
that if that that may not be true but
let's just assume
it is and and the response to that would
be that
that comes out the need of something
because there there is equal value or
equally emptiness of value
in everything we've talked about today
because there isn't any real separation
for anything to become
a need it is already complete
perfect in that it couldn't be
any other way there is no comparison
because everything that
you mention is everything
so there's no way to compare and in that
sense it's com
it's perfect
where we're playing right now is
interesting
because the
equal emptiness of value
is the infinite
eternal and non-dual and
even
the illusory multiplicity is
ineffable it's all ineffable
yet the most
outward in the
this dualistic concessional
juxtaposition
in that in that outwardness of the
of the value system that
there's a there's a nesting
of sorts it's like the nesting is
a it's like the nesting's concentric
circles with the non-dual eternal
infinite with another nested circle
inside of that which is the dualistic
concession of very similar to the
taijitsu which has the monism
and then it has the yin yang dualism on
the inside
and then there's also another concentric
circle which is the multiplicity
the eight billion apparent bodies
that are the creative expression
of the non-dual infinite
and it just it appears as though
there is a synthesis
of the east
in its non-dual infinite eternal
along with what is in the west this
gratitude that we were expressing a
moment ago
which is the infinite
creative expression through the apparent
individual where you get the
technology of these devices and of these
electric vehicles and of these
eradications of people not having food
and water and that is
something to be celebrate celebrated
and that's where it is
what appears as a synthesis between
the that non-dual
infinite eternal eastern with the sort
of
western creative
expression of the infinite
through these individuals how does that
resonate not it there isn't there is no
duality
duality is exactly like you described
these two things and this and that and
what
what might not be what what what we're
talking about here is that this
or this or that
is everything
there is only everything
and it never separates and yet it is
only everything and yet you're the gym
unit character and i'm the atlas
unit character but it's in the dream and
it's
an appeal the character is an appearance
and whatever appears is everything
so there's no real movement there's no
real separation
there aren't really two things happening
there's only
everything whatever that is whatever
this is it's all there is
it is the dream of the individual that
this is really happening
which then projects out that there's
something else really happening
so you don't play with the value system
there isn't any value
there's just simply no value value is
the need of the individual it's the
story it tells itself
that the appearance has some lacking in
some way
value is the story i tell myself of
becoming
and my value
you're not going to go and eat a piece
of
garbage yeah but
it depends on depends on what we what
you call garbage do you know what you
know what they call
sushi in texas no
what do they call it bait yeah
you know like if you go fishing you have
babies oh i get it i get it that's yeah
that's funny
but it doesn't need to have a value
system for there to be
an appreciation of food of one side or
the other
i may i'm i see
this whole thing with when there's a
billion people around the planet that
are still figuring out access to clean
water and
abundant sources of food i
and the west in many ways
get really excited about this apparent
individual which is really just the
creative expression of the
infinite of the non-dual that
is a motivating force
saying ah we are executing these next
generation
architectures that eradicate the 100
million people in this part of the world
that don't have access to that
clean water and food and then there's
this applause
for the company and for the employees
and the excitement there
and see and that is in a sense
that's in a value system
that's more beautiful
than the lethargic
apathetic expression of the
infinite which is sitting and
eating fast food
and just shoving that in its mouth and
very gluttonous
and lazy and so yeah so does
yeah so so that's just the story of the
individual
trying to find something of value and
judging fast food as not good because it
has the
the belief that there is something good
that will bring about
what it's looking for that will bring
about wholeness
and the experiences seafood fast food
won't bring about
wholeness but eating brown rice or
vegetables or whatever
will bring about wholeness but yet
you're simply
not what seems to be happening what's
that but you're but yet you're not
eating
fast food every single day because you
know that as a value system that that's
going to
create a that's just not the way it is
that
that part i mean the individual
if there is one will then add on to its
actions
value system but generally the body will
eat what feels good
what what brings what brings you know
what what
what feels good it's as though there's
no value to it at all
in that sense that you're talking about
there is no more
value in in clean water than
unclean water there's nothing wrong
really helping people
with helping people so interesting well
it's all
what's being pointed to is the non-dual
it
there is only the non-dual it's it's
it is never duality it's the dream of
the individual
and it is in that dream do you prefer
clean water
but you prefer clean water you you see
what i'm saying
yeah and and that sort of makes
this conversation beautiful because
there is only the non-dual where there's
no value between clean water
and dirty water and yet then in the
dualistic concession
there is i definitely prefer clean water
but the preference of clean water is
just simply what's happening there's no
value in that
it's simply what's happening yeah okay
but yet there's a
preference for the clean water there's
all sorts of preferences
yeah yeah this is that was that was an
exploration right there
oh so there's all sorts of preferences
so there's the preference for well-being
that's sort of what you would say is
there's all sorts of preferences
well some people have a preference for
too much cheese
and they there's a preference to eat
more cheese than is healthy
and so they get gall stones that's just
what's happening
some people have a preference for
smoking
it seems as though the
the celebration
of the infinite expressing itself
creatively through the illusory
individuals
is what has
enabled this is also creativity that's
what i'm saying
that's great nothing else yeah it's also
the absolute
it doesn't come through and become
something else
it is that it's so it's so it it just
rolls off it's like water on a duck's
back
there isn't two things going on there is
only the infinite
there isn't the infinite becoming it is
when the end when the experience of the
infinite becoming and there's something
else going on
that then value comes into it because
the experience of the individual
in that experience of separation is that
something's missing
so in the taijitsu which i feel is
probably one of the greatest symbols
that's ever been made
there's this monist non-dual
infinite eternal and then there's the
dualistic
yin yang within it and that
the there is no becoming
like you've been saying there's only the
being or the apparent being
and that is the monist and then the
dualistic becoming is something along
the lines of that
you did go from a zygote to 30 trillion
cells
and you have and which is this and you
do have the preference
of clean water instead of dirty water
yeah
that's fascinating
uh and this is what i was talking to you
about and actually rita as well your
wife
who does so much epic behind the scenes
stuff to actually make
help this make this happen that these
are
the styles of dialectic
that a lot of the non-dual community
is interested in hearing
because there's a lot of
there's a lot of people that
are trying to figure out
what we just talked about a moment ago
because in a sense the
the description this dualistic
description that we did a moment ago of
there being the preference for clean
water
is something that people
feel all the time that they have this
preference towards clean water rather
than dirty water
but that when if if the if the
non-dual
paradoxical message that's
being expressed in the appearance
through the jim
newman unit is coming out there is no
value system
that yes that then people
say that yes but what about the
preference for me choosing or for it
coming through to choose
now you're back to free will and choice
of which there isn't any
yes correct no free will no choice and
yet this unit this character
is has a preference has a preference
which is not dualistic preferences
aren't dualistic
okay well they can be described with
two poles in a spectrum
okay but that's not dualistic either
there is there is only
what seems to be happening there's never
two things
and so this is sort of what i what i was
just mentioning is that it's like the
simultaneity
of the non-dual infinite eternal
wholeness perfection
appear apparent happening with the
simultaneous i'm
it's coming through to have a preference
towards clean water rather than dirty
water
so it doesn't come through it is it's
not
yeah it is the preference it appears as
a preference i say come through because
then
that makes it so that there's not an
attachment to choice and free will
that's there isn't but there as long as
there's an individual
there's no it doesn't this isn't about
detachment as long as there's an
individual there's an experience
of choice and free will
just like there's an experience of value
and experience of meaning and purpose
that's just part and parcel of the
experience of separation
and yet you would it be fair to say that
you enjoy a nice
night out with rita in
austria and versus you know if you're
having to lay on the couch
behind you because you have very severe
knee pain and you
and you and you you you have a clear
preference there's a clear preference
there are preferences but preferences
are what seems to be
i feel as though the taijitsu plays a
massive role
in what we're
playing with right now and why it was
formulated
over a thousand years ago and
there is no thousand yeah yeah yeah yeah
i know i'm aware
i'm aware
i love it i love it see that's the thing
in the in the taijitsu it would be like
there is no thousand years ago in the
most
nondual monist sense and then in the
dualistic
concession sense it would be like well
yeah
i guess technically 30 years ago there
were
no laptops and now we're using these
laptops to talk
but that thought is this appearing as
that
thought there is no real 30 years ago
the non-dual appearing as the thought
of talking about 30 years ago
it's really not that complicated there's
just what appears and it can appear as
anything
it's limitless without lemon and it can
appear as a thought
of 8 billion people having more water or
or not or a computer or a zygote
or that symbol that you mentioned i
can't remember what it is the thai jit
ii
yeah it can appear as anything
there is nothing that's dual there is no
thing all of this is no thing
being this sometimes it
there's the interpretation of the
non-dual
which is that the
individual which is
an apparent
an individual's illusory and there's no
such thing as non-duality
interesting
yeah i'm yeah yep
cool cool it's just
the thing that it it is
very much
something that the non-dual community
which doesn't exist
is it exists as that thought as the
thought
um that is
playing with is that when the individual
is so
negated as an illusion that then
there's no celebration like a big
confetti
about the beauty of
the expression of and because it
appears it lives in a world of need
and so it looks for celebration well it
is just an eternal celebration this is
just eternal fireworks no but that's not
what you were describing a second ago
you were describing the the non-dual
community that has the sense of the
individual being negated negates the
celebration of this
and i my the response was the individual
is just needing it never gets enough
it'll never have enough
even if even if we were to agree or
somehow
come to the conclusion that everything
is celebration for the individual it
wouldn't be enough
there's just not enough for the
individual for that experience of
separation
it's always experiencing the loss
of the aliveness that this is already
so if everything is the celebration then
even dirty water is as
celebrated as clean water absolutely
yeah
see this is this is the but i would have
to say unconditional celebration
because it there's no way to point
to what this is okay i'm following now
okay cool
and when you say unconditional it is no
longer
relatable it's no longer relevant that
points to
the limitlessness of the appearance the
beginning and endlessness
of the appearance and then would it
be do you do you
resonate with the word surrender
that's just something that the
individual is looking for the individual
one of the basic
experiences is that something needs to
happen for this to be
what's looked for or more
that's what's longed for and it never
happens and that experience is
not this the next something else
something else that's just the
experience nobody could
and surrender is the idea that there's
someone with free will and choice that
could give that up
and that that hides the reality that
giving that up
is also what's next it's also the need
for something to happen
okay yeah unconditional celebration
that's all there is beautiful
and that's why francis lucille talked
about it as an eternal
fireworks hmm yeah
yeah and yet this apparent unit
or vehicle is has the preference
of clean water of fireworks
that are not
food that is going to give me heart
disease
you know so but it's
ineffable there's no way to point to the
unconditional celebration because there
is only that
because there is only that because
everywhere you point is the
unconditional celebration the pointing
as well
the pointing is as well yeah
perfect yeah that's that's a great
place to to rap
freedom appearing is another way to
potentially talk about that the
unconditional celebration is freedom
appearing
cool cool yeah i like that as well
and then oh this would be interesting
what about what about this
apparent expression
that this has or that this
is the trying to trying to take
the unconditional
freedom and unconditional celebration
that we're talking about and trying to
package that
up into videos and
and animated series and art and
books it's just what happens
yeah and the person that picks up a gun
and murder somebody else is just what
happens
yeah and so is the one that stops him
and so is the one that stops him or
doesn't or doesn't
see what we're getting into is the
experience that the individual has free
will and choice
and could choose to do something or some
or not do something
that's just part of the illusory control
that the individual feels it has over
the appearance
when we say all is unconditional
freedom celebration that can also be
synonymous with the worst thing you can
think of
with the with the non yeah it can be
synonymous with the worst thing you can
think of and it can be synonymous with
with god well i mean
or or or pizza or pizza
okay fair fair
wow so yeah so the unconditional
celebration is built synonymous with the
100 million people that died
in the 20th century and
it's also synonymous with pizza
[Laughter]
what this is crazy
oh my gosh got it this is so crazy
jeez it's like
yeah a billion people that get access to
clean water
is a piece there aren't a billion people
are there is a pizza which is
a murder that's happening which is the
invention of the printing press which
is yeah yeah and then
yeah this actually it's the telegraph
was the most profound change
in society of all time the telegraph
because it was the first time we could
send information
that made a biggest that was they say
you know who were they i don't know
but they say that was one of the biggest
evolutionary steps
the telegraph but evolution
is a illusion
no it's really simple man the only
illusion is the individual
everything else but evolution is not an
is
not an illusion it's an appearance it's
an appearance
yeah so evolution is an appearance just
like this becoming is an appearance
becoming is a dream if we're talking
about personal becoming
it's a dream of the individual it never
happens is evolution a dream
no it's an appearance it's an appearance
but the different words is um
if we're talking about the individual
becoming that's a dream there is no
individual to become
if we're talking about the wheel
becoming a lamborghini that's an
appearance
what's not what's completely unreal is
that there's a person
that has free will and choice
that has a real experience of separation
that's just completely illusory
when with it comes the sense that things
have value
that the appearance has meaning and
purpose that
is completely illusory that never
happens
everything else is simply what's
appearing
and it's neither real nor unreal
so the zygote is an appearance
is the past is an appearance
the thought of eight billion people just
like evolution is an appearance
so evolutions and appearances i got as
an appearance
the wheel evolving into the lamborghini
is an appearance
yep seemed to but becoming is an
illusion
the becoming of the individual that
there is a process
of wholeness that will become at some
point
through my personal development that
appearance is related to me
that is completely illusory got it
the becoming of the individual yeah
going through this gateless gate
is is a dream is a dream it's an
illusion
yeah is it never happens it's an
illusion
but evolution from a zygote to
a human adult or the wheel to the
lamborghini
that is an appearance yeah okay but then
that is not becoming
well i mean we can say we can talk about
as a a
tire becoming a lamborghini okay we can
okay yeah okay
it's not personal yeah it's not personal
i see now now i'm following
so that's why you specifically added
individual when you said becoming
but at the same time it's still just
this
yeah evolution is this appearing as
evolution
the wheel becoming a lamborghini is this
appearing as the wheel becoming a
lamborghini
all right and just to clarify
this point is that
and we can wrap with this that the
infinite modulations
or the infinite combinations
are appearing
and that this is that
appearance and it's neither real nor
unreal
this is the infinite internet doesn't
become
there is only the infinite cool
there is only the infinite and yet
there is a zygote that apparently
becomes an adult
yeah which is this the infinite
appearing as the story of a zogo
becoming an adult which is this
okay okay cool
cool
[Laughter]
oh wow yeah jim this is
this is awesome i'm ridiculously
grateful
that you talked to us and thanks thanks
for
inviting me thank you thank you
yeah jim's got an awesome
amount of content on his website with
essays and videos you can check out
again at simply dash this dot com
and then also his youtube channels just
got
all of his meetings that he's held
across the world
in the last several years he has those
filmed
and they're on his youtube channel go
and watch those there's a lot of
great content there and
also the zooms that
jim holds happen monthly and you can
join
those by simply going to the website and
there's a button for the
zoom and meetings and then you can sign
up for that
hopefully what we can do is
also get jim in conversation
with other communicators of the
of the non-dual paradoxical message
on the channel which is part of our plan
is to get
maybe with this atlas unit to get the
jim
newman unit with maybe other units on
the subject which will be exciting
that is all we're really grateful and
appreciative
for you guys for tuning in thank you so
much
and we would love to hear from you in
the comments below let us know
what you're thinking what you're feeling
in the comments below
and like the video if it brought you
value subscribe if you haven't yet
also share the video with other people
that you
feel like would bring value to and again
go and check out all of
jim's awesome links below we love you
very much thank you everybody for tuning
in
thank you so much again jim we're
ridiculously grateful this was fantastic
this is fantastic thanks man all right
thank you everybody we will talk to you
soon
peace